thank you thank you ladies and gentlemen
good evening everyone it's wonderful to
be here we're in a house of God
but I can promise you that I'm not going
to treat this panel with any reverence
at all tonight and neither should you
welcome to this debate in the spirit of
the age I'm tempted to say I have never
seen a crowd like this in my life in
fact this must be the biggest debate
crowd that London has ever seen you are
fabulous people all of you fabulous but
I'm not going to do that because we're
not going to be talking about Donald
Trump tonight we are going to be
reflecting on another nation which has
political challenges shall we say and a
degree of turmoil in its midst and that
is our very own dear country the title
of our debate tonight is as you all know
the great realignment Britain's
political identity crisis there could be
nothing more timely I think given that
we all know that politics is in a state
of flux we have had in the recent past
leaders like Tony Blair and David
Cameron who were intent preoccupied with
winning the center ground but right now
politics is a place where the center
ground doesn't really seem to matter
quite so much there are more extremes I
would say in British politics today and
then questions for all of us about where
we sit with what we see in our politics
our party politics our brexit politics
our nationalist politics all of this is
up for grabs and is raising profound
questions about the alignment of British
politics so that's what we're going to
explore I'm going to introduce my
fantastic panel in just a moment but
because this is an evening which is all
about your involvement you're gonna get
I guarantee you a chance to air your own
questions much better than mine I am
sure to our panel
it's about interactivity so we're going
to start by getting ourselves ready for
total engagement with an audience
question for you all so please on a show
of hands
to set out how we feel as we go into
this debate please think about this and
respond how many of you all of you here
tonight right now are feeling
politically homeless
if you're feeling politically homeless
raise a hand now this is awkward because
I can't quite I don't I think it's about
half perhaps raisin waggle them around
really violently oh yo God it's more
than half actually it's it's
three-quarters okay it's a very useful
guide to our panel
would you agree panel about three
quarters you want to recount all right
who has actually got a clear political
home right now and feels they know where
their home and their identity sits Wagle
please yeah I'm sorry you're not a
majority your eyes I'll be charitable
and say you're a third your between a
quarter and a third so homelessness
political homelessness is going to be a
big theme of this evening thank you for
that everybody let me very quickly
introduce the panel I'm just going to go
down the line so I'm going to start with
Anand Menon who is professor of European
politics and foreign affairs at King's
College London also director of UK in a
changing Europe which he insists is the
best think-tank
in Britain today he's not of course
biased at all it is he says a
non-partisan initiative researching the
complex relationship between the UK and
the EU next to an an a familiar figure
I'm sure to all of you Hillary been a
very senior figure in the Labour Party
not currently in the shadow cabinet but
he has served in labour cabinets and he
is currently chair of the parliamentary
brexit Select Committee next to Hillary
is David Goodheart
he is the founding editor of Prospect
magazine he's currently the head of the
demography unit at the think-tank policy
exchange and because he's an author he
insists I tell you that his role his
the road to somewhere the populist
revolt in the future of politics is
available outside this hall depending on
the quality of his argument you may or
may not be interested in that by the end
of the evening for you to judge not me
next to David we have Helen Lewis Helen
is deputy editor at the New Statesman
writes a great deal about the political
scene in this country she also
broadcasts on it I know because I
listened to her on the week in
Westminster on Radio 4 and frightening
Li for a tech Luddite like me she also
has a weekly tech column in The Sunday
Times which I read but don't understand
and then at the end of our panel we have
Ken Clark course is this a kind or an
unkind word a veteran of the House of
Commons I think father of the house
indeed that's one of the most absurd
titles I've ever had in my career
I don't want to compete I don't think I
fathered any longer DNA testing will not
be required so we won't go further into
that but I have a list here of all Ken's
cabinet posts it's it's so long and
arguably tedious that I won't go into it
but but Chancellor of the Exchequer is a
highlight
also the fact that I run into him
occasionally at the kennington tandoori
is also a highlight so there we are a
warm hand for all of my panel
[Applause]
in the spirit of panel debate and to get
things going I want to hear from each of
you in turn on this very simple
straightforward opening question is
Britain facing a political identity
crisis right now let me start with you
David yes I think it is but political
identity crises are necessary in
politics they have to happen every now
and then because views of the electorate
shift and the party system gets out of
kilter with how public opinion has
changed I think what's been happening I
think the big thing that's been
happening over the last generation or so
is that that's that we've seen a kind of
convergence of views on most the big
socio-economic issues it may not look
like that given the Corbyn take over the
Labor Party but actually if you look at
British social attitudes surveys and so
on things like public spending
redistribution size of the state you've
seen actually a convergence across
classes and value groups to some extent
to I think the middle class is more
egalitarian than it used to be perhaps
that's because there's a bigger graduate
professional element to it the working
class is less protectionist than it used
to be so you see you've seen it coming
together on socio-economic issues across
the country however on socio-cultural
issues it's used to do with the
nation-state and borders and group
attachment and peace of change and
issues to do with with terrorism and
crime on these sorts of issues you've
seen a divergence of views across the
country and our party system doesn't
really reflect this any longer
there was a kind of mariz arme had got
a big majority at the last election I
think that the realignment would have
started it's we've had a kind of half a
realignment
but at the moment we are we are not
seeing this shift I mean obviously
socio-economic if politics remains very
important but socio-cultural politics
has become so much more important and is
now the deferment I think what will
happen over the next 10 15 20 years is
where we will have a more liberal but I
mean that some version of the Labour
Party
middle version of the Labour Party
representing the broad middle class that
is that is somewhat more liberal more
open in favor more openness and so on
than the Conservative Party that will
they won't care more about national
boundaries and and and the security and
identity issues I mean I think that work
and a half we haven't quite realigned
yet but we will do right and you're
still I don't want to focus right now on
this the opening aren't too much on
party politics but you're still focusing
on two main parties dominating in the
future as far as you put it yeah but but
can you next the basic notion of a
political identity crisis cause crises
are bad things and therefore this is a
notion that something bad is happening
do you think it is well crisis is very
very much on the European issue which is
why it's been the poison in British
politics throughout the last thirty
years I mean essentially any people on
the center-right know where they differ
from the center left I feel quite
comfortable I think a lot of voters do
on most issues
I mean Jenkins it--some Blair I'd
suppose distinguish themselves from one
nation conservatives and outliers have
joined in our two-party system in off
taking their voters with them with some
very loyal bloc voters in the past now
Europe's always strain that there's no
party unity on Europe on either side of
the aisle and the electorate realigns
itself and it's been doing so evermore
dramatically in recent times so that the
Labour Party's dependence on the
certainly the ageing white working-class
in the north has you know they can't
they're gone when they stop voting but
you keep a lot and voted for us our
reliance on young professional
aspirational business and professional
people in the south and southeast it's
gone so this extraordinary general
election we win Mansfield and they lose
Canterbury and so they will ever win the
bridge well but that was reflected all
over the place and in the House of
Commons the hardline Euroskeptics
people like Jeremy Corbyn
people like Liam Fox with identical
views sitting cabinets and shadow
cabinets and try to append to agree with
people whose pro-european views are at
least as strong as Hillary's in my own
and that's why it because of all
underlying angry protests that's why
things are broken up why it's broken up
particularly and remember it's partly
the economic collapse it's the loss of
confidence in the global economy a lot
of people haven't benefited we haven't
really recovered from the 2007 2008
crisis and the other is the mass surge
of migrants into this country which is
causing a huge problem for all the
Democratic West and which a section of
the public is getting increasingly
alarmed about and they want to find
scapegoats for the fact that the
community is changing and they rather
like if blaming Mexicans and one of you
to build a wall if Americans or blaming
Brussels and thinking you will all stop
if any we leave the European Union here
yeah thanks Karen we'll come back to
specific issues like immigration I'm
sure in the course of the debate but
Helen
the the big picture I mean Ken's just
painted this topsy-turvy world where the
Tories win Mansfield when they actually
performed pretty badly overall and labor
extraordinarily wins places like
Kensington and Chelsea and Canterbury as
well topsy-turvy but is it bad and and
what do you make of this notion of an
identity crisis I think it is bad
because I think it means that voting is
very frothy and unpredictable and
actually as we saw tonight lots of
people do feel homeless I think there
are a couple of devices that are now
really strong and can pick this up but
what we've really seen is the decline of
class-based voting actually you cannot
talk about there being this big class
bit anymore and that's been replaced by
different divides so absolutely huge one
is graduates versus non graduates 90% of
our MPs are graduates now that is a
problem because you have grant
government by graduates for graduates
look at the brig's it votes 75% of
people with a postgraduate qualification
voted remain linked to economic class
absolutely it's neat to me well because
it doesn't matter so much where you came
from is where you feel you're going and
I think that's the different thing about
where the economy who the economy is
perceived to work for but the other big
split as well which also relates to this
is city versus country
that's the story of Kensington really is
that people in cities live alongside
migrants and immigrants and ethnic
diversity but they are far more relaxed
about that than there's somebody who is
living in a predominantly white town has
seen relatively small but dramatic
changes in a sort of percentage terms so
somewhere like Boston in Lincolnshire
was the most Briggs is where I'm from in
the country and actually if you compare
that with an in the London borough that
has not had the volume of migration that
you would see there but it has had a
very rapid change so there are the other
big one that I would mention is old
versus young and this was an election
where Labour did a lot better than
expected to because youth turnout was
very very high and that's a long-term
problem for the Tories because the two
stories really of their vote chair are
over 65s were repelled by the social
care offer and stayed at home and also
they're missing generation of Tory
voters around the ages of 35 to 44
people whom once might expected to buy a
house settle down and vote Tory and
they're stuck in the private rented
sector they feel so much more insecure
in their lives and they're not turning
to the Conservative Party in the way
that their their parents or their
grandparents probably would have gone
through that trajectory of their lives
so yeah what we've seen is exactly an
identity crisis politics is becoming so
much more unpredictable I was looking at
data today that suggested that between
the brexit referendum 1/3 of the people
who turned out for that either sorry
2015 election either 1/3 of those people
who voted in the 2015 election either
stayed at home or voted for a different
party in 2017 that is an incredible
level of churn in politics yeah Hilary
to you next and again the theme the
identity crisis but I'm just wondering
whether it is such a bad thing you know
Helen kicked off by saying yes it is bad
and turbulence froth all of this sort of
churn in in politics but why is it it
makes you lot take much less for granted
maybe makes you work harder and think
harder so way maybe it isn't a bad thing
that we're talking about well it's
interesting
in recent years we we've been told the
growth of multi-party politics but
actually the election we had this year
eighty-two point four percent of people
either voted labour or conservative and
you have to go back I think to 1970 to
find the last time here
that figure was to be found look the
nation is absolutely split down the
middle on bricks it and Ken is right
that it is the the issue that dominates
our our politics and we're having to
deal with the consequences now what is
that about the 52% voted to leave
because it was about migration change a
loss austerity how long you wait to see
the doctor the inability to find housing
for your children and a desire for
control the word of the referendum in a
world in which because of the pace of
change it often seems as if too many
people we have barely any control at all
and I think the message that the
referendum sent which is not just for
the United Kingdom but politics across
certainly a Western countries is the
balance between on the one hand the
recognition of the need for cooperation
between nation states to deal with
terrorism to deal with threats to peace
and security the movement of people
climate change trade and on the other
hand the wish to have some greater
influence about how things work in our
country and what we've seen now is that
on top of traditional party politics we
now have over laid referendum politics
and I agree with Ken that each of our
parties is having to deal with the
consequences of that because we
represent people who were on either
sides of the particular debate and the
last thing I would say is that in a
society where since the end of the
Second World War the story we have told
ourselves is of onwards upwards better
generation my generation we look at our
children and we realize in terms of
stable and secure job ability to afford
a home to be able to save for a pension
we know that our children as things
stand at the moment are not going to
enjoy the same life that we've enjoyed
and that is quite a challenge for
politics so perhaps it's not surprising
that there is this crisis that we're
debating here tonight just in
parentheses I was fascinated to look at
your face when Ken referred to Jeremy
Corbyn as a die-hard euro skeptic do you
accept that do you know he vote campaign
for and voted remain
as you know Steve as my kids say to me
I'm just messing with you there were in
the most Delfy could the strange way had
his own personal reasons maybe in gym
you know what I was let's save this one
for later it is time to hear from Anand
and what I would say is you know we here
we are in London and actually hands up
how many of you are actually Londoners
and how many have well that how many of
you are Londoners Wagle so we oh my god
you almost all are yeah so and Helen and
others have already referred to the new
divide one of which is sort of
Metropolitan against country urban but
particularly London frankly more than
anywhere against sort of other parts of
the country and and non-urban areas so
so we've got a London audience we've got
a panel who if I may say so I know not
all of you are from London but you all
sound quite you know London ish you know
what I mean I mean in in in in the most
most well-spoken sense but Anand I know
is from from Wakefield in Yorkshire just
like I'm from Lincolnshire you have a
perspective that isn't necessarily what
it isn't London so when you answer this
question about political identity crisis
and and reflect as well on the degree to
which you hear a lot of stuff outside
London that you don't necessarily hear
in London well first I mean the survey
has yet to be designed that paints me as
the archetypal denizen of wake
[Laughter]
I am NOT gonna stand there as a
representative of my hometown but uh
outside sit doesn't I'll say two things
I'll say it's interesting that both MPs
put the emphasis on Europe because I
think Europe is part of the story of our
politics but only part of it because I
think the other part of the story is the
fact that from the early part of this
century onwards politics had been
distancing itself from the people you
see this in all sorts of ways you see in
falling party membership falling voter
turnout you see it in all the British
social attitudes polling on whether
people trusted politicians the fact that
more and more people said they were all
the same added to that you have the
expenses crisis added to that you had
the impact of the financial crisis and I
think there was a growing disenchantment
with politics there anyway before the
referendum what the referendum did in
part was it allowed people to express
that so the other figure about comparing
2015 with the general election in 2016
is that 3 million people who couldn't
find anyone to vote for in the general
election went out and voted in the
referendum and the majority of those
people voted to leave partly as a
protest against their system so that's
the first thing and the second thing is
to do with Europe and this is why it's
so messy we have two problems going at
once we have the disillusion with
politics and with the centrist politics
of the Blair Cameron days and secondly
we have this new divide the divide over
Europe which is basically David's values
divide one of the greatest predictors of
how people voted in the referendum was
their view on authoritarianism versus
liberalism or the death penalty or whole
number of ciphers we have those that
divide added and as everyone has said so
far our political parties can't cope
with that divide because it goes
straight through them so having the
first crisis alone to deal with me would
probably be enough for our political
system having both of them is leading to
what we see nowadays in our politics as
to whether or not this is good or bad
what I would say is let's see what comes
out of it
I mean if at the end of the day for me
personally this is a purely personal
view we end up in 10 years time with a
Britain that is far more equal and the
disparities between rich and poor north
and south and so far have disappeared to
an extent that I said that was a very
handy crisis thank you very much we end
up with a whole different future then
I'll reassess
okay you just said something interesting
and I want to pick up on it yeah about
the the the center ground and the degree
to which politics at the moment appears
to have left the center ground and III
mentioned it to do you think that's
really true because you know that the
received wisdom in in democratic
politics not just in this country but in
most Western democracies is that you win
by winning the center ground is that no
longer a safe assumption to make in the
United Kingdom today III think we
exaggerate that I think there's a huge
support still you know eighty ninety
percent of the electorate support what
Bob a regulated market economy a by
historical standards a very large state
you know a kind of forty percent state
Tories may want 38 percent late in May
one forty two percent I mean these are
relatively sort of minor disputes and a
public realm that is that is pretty
egalitarian and permissive in its
assumptions about about our fellow
citizens are I mean within you know so
that's that's very big picture within
there of course we have the value
divisions and these value groups I call
them in my book of the any where people
who are about 25 percent of population
that the more educated and mobile people
and the somewhere people about 50
percent who tend to be much more rooted
less less well-educated so on that these
value divides had have partly taken over
from the the class division are real and
important and are leading to this this
this this this identity crisis you might
say but it doesn't detract from the fact
you know I mean look around the world
you know just remember you know actually
what a high degree of consensus there is
on the very very big picture stuff yeah
but but you could argue in in British
politics today I mean for example before
the quite extraordinary election result
the received wisdom was I don't know
Hillary whether you would acknowledge
this but the received wisdom was that
that jeremy corbyn's offer you know an
out now will effort offer was never
going to appeal successfully to the
British public as the British public on
the whole always reverted to some sort
of centrism
you could argue Corbin's blown that
apart and you could also argue
that because the Tory party at the
moment seems to be driven by people who
are very passionately Pro brexit and I
think in the past you've used the word
headbangers about some of them that that
both are main political parties are
being driven by people who aren't that
fussed about the center ground in the
labor manifesto I think that's a
fascinating thing if people have this
idea and it's one of the reasons for
jeremy corbyn's appeal is that he's a
very radical figure but you look at that
manifesto and it was a soft left
manifesto
okay so taxing people over 80,000 pounds
a year is something that we haven't been
allowed to say for 20 or 30 years in
British politics but it's not it's
hardly full communism now is it really
and also your nationalization
I mean if an Andrew adonus under the
Blair government was talking about
individual bidding contracts for rail
companies and I don't think there's
anybody here who would argue that the
privatization of rail has been an
unqualified success
right who are these people that there
are I think and part of the reason that
Jeremy Corbyn succeeded is that the tour
was also offering a very radical change
there was no status quo at this election
and therefore I think it's it's it's
very odd to talk about the idea that you
know the center ground is completely
gone because Corbin is this very very
radical figure I mean in some ways the
Tory manifest it was to the left of the
labor manifest doing but on the
intergenerational justice thing after
all the Tories were proposing to reduce
subsidies for the affluent old and
Labour was proposing to increase
subsidies for the affluent young by
abolishing tuition fees I mean was
extraordinary but it was a policy either
side produced through entire elections
it was abandoned after two days they had
I don't think Corbin's policies played a
part in it really his personality and
the desire to protest a lot of people
voted for him confident because all the
pundits told him this and he wasn't
going to win anyway and to save him from
oblivion really so it was an
extraordinary result and I I don't think
he chose any serves two extremes amongst
the public the basic centuries the views
of the British people are still there
and I won't go but we go on but there
it's the actual political world itself
just
Bentley got itself into this situation
where eat produces more extremists than
it used to and is no longer dominated by
its center it's a reaction really to the
cynicism which I agree is as an
extraordinary ludicrous height ever I
mean the expenses crisis scandal was a
genuine scandal but the adolescent
cynical view of the average member of
the public who will tell you they're all
crooks they all lie there's no
difference between them they're only in
it for they get out of it that carries
80% of the public the result is they
won't join political parties they
weren't anything to do with them they
dislike them as inspect Labour's
membership is a record-high yeah but
it's not representative they have a very
young membership which is very left-wing
it doesn't remotely represent the broad
brush of Labor voters we have a very
small membership of ageing people who
really fight right-wing and not remotely
representative of the general
conservative vote and this pretty and
both parties rather stupidly gave in to
some campaigns to to democratize
themselves so the actual leadership of
the parties and the pressures within the
parties are driven by these
unrepresentative groups and if we had
went back to the days of mass membership
we would have a centrist one nation
modernizing leader if the Labour Party
could reverse this ridiculous rule that
gave anybody a vote for three quid they
would go back to having some you like
Hillary as their leader and so against a
disconnect between the political party
system in Parliament and the general
electorate but I agree with those who
said the basic instincts of the sensible
bulk of the electric will they be left
or right can we define someone's already
defined enough to calculate their to
come back to the question what why
restrict yourself
all right there is certainly wonderful
error haha we can wonder oh I think it
remains the case that to win you have to
win the center ground but I think it is
also the case that where the center
ground is now has shifted and I think
that is why the manifesto which got a
very good reception if you take the
example of the housing crisis take the
private rented sector the eleven million
people that you mentioned there is a
much greater appetite now for longer
term tendencies for tenants caps on rent
increases during the terms of the
tenancy indeed our policy which I helped
develop on Armistice shadow communities
and local government secretary that
lettings agent fees should no longer be
paid by tenants but by the landlord has
actually been pinched by the government
and I think that is an example of where
opinion has moved for the reasons I
think that Anand set out so clearly
people see the things that aren't
working and therefore a much more
willing to be open to parties and people
who come along and say well here's
something that we can do about them and
people say well yes that makes sense
that's something I will vote for and
railway nationally nationalization I
have to tell you is fantastically
popular around the country I used to
travel for five years on the only
state-owned railway in the UK east coast
trains and when they came to relent the
contract the government said any railway
company in the world including every
state-owned railway company can bid the
only people who can't bid to take on
that contract other people or abolutely
owned have been running it up that's
ideology I don't even run through every
item in the labor manifesto I use it as
an illustrator and I want to hear from
you and I've got another question well
I'd say a couple of things I think
probably on balance I'd agree that the
views of the British public have
remained pretty consistent over the last
twenty years there is probably haven't
gone off to the extremes themselves but
I think there are some elements of what
was the sort of sentries consensus of
our politics for so long that are being
challenged now they're the ones to do
with openness globalization trade and
things like that it's exactly where we
were before I think there are important
parts of the debate that have changed
more open that is because people's lives
have been changed by European
integration but Otto I have freedom of
movement and freedom of movement it
impacts different groups very
differently but also yeah okay well all
those things that Alan's just mentioned
you know trade globalization or those
are precisely the the grounds the issues
upon which in the United States Donald
Trump appeal to so many angry pissed-off
people so address this panel anger how
much of a factor in the United Kingdom
today and in our political realignment
if that's what we are seeing is just
out-and-out
anger from a lot of people in this
country or are we not angry in the same
way so many disaffected particularly
white working-class people appear to be
in America in no way as angry as America
is and I think that's a very sensible
and good way to be I mean but look it
we're not we're not hacked off it would
be mildly perturbed you know so British
that's what we do you know when you're
talking really about centrism I think
it's from those fascinating things
because we watch a lot of American TV
programs that are made on the coast we
use a lot of American tech that is made
in San Francisco we have a vision of
what America is that is entirely
incorrect and actually we are much more
European than we ever know but because
very few of us speaking our language we
don't realize and look across Europe
this year you've had a series of
centrist politicians winning Angela
Merkel looks likely to be returned in
Germany macro in France and I think that
the difference with America is that you
have got incredible poverty I mean it is
a statistic that astonishes me there is
no federally mandated maternity leave in
America so if you are a woman you're
pregnant and your job doesn't offer you
any benefits you have to use your
holiday entitlement to have a baby
and that is something that if you try to
put that past British people we'd go
what and I don't think that's why you
you were talking about you know anger
state neurs who won the Nobel Prize for
this great research on deaths of despair
the fact that life expectancy is
actually going down among white
working-class people because of things
like the opioid epidemic because of
things like heart disease rates and
obesity that is not being treated you
know people are living really really
troubled lives in America that actually
with the European social security
welfare net we actually find quite
difficult to imagine and those are not
the people or on our TV think so those
who characterize brexit as a howl of
anger from people you know save just for
argument's sake in Middlesbrough or Hull
or Boston Lincolnshire or wherever
they're talking nonsence are they
it isn't really wasn't really driven by
saying this but the only funny things
about Briggs is a howl of anger from
people whose lives are actually pretty
good
after you talking about the over 65s I
mean certainly in terms of what their
children can expect I think that's one
of the biggest for me and most difficult
questions in British politics is why is
a generation whose living standards are
so much better than expected when they
were young so angry and they are angry
in the richest part of the country in
West London boom and I think you know
mild perturbation does become slightly
more extreme perturbation if that's the
right concept for the further north in
parts of the Midlands and parts of the
north and I've you know I mean this
extraordin
question that the people are asked this
opinion survey question people it is
suggested to people it is rather a
leading question I admit but a lot of
people say Britain has changed in recent
times many people feel like it's become
a foreign country
something like 63 percent of the public
agree with that I mean it's astonishing
in a country you know it's rich and
successful and basically stable as ours
there are a lot of people who do think
society has changed far too fast and not
in and not in a way that is consistent
with their interests that you know
people are not in this whole cannot open
the closed thing it's a very
self-serving
way of saying are we've moved on from
left free right it's now open V closed
I've never met anyone who wants to live
in a closed society no bet people don't
live in the closer they just think the
forms of openness we've developed in in
the recent decades have not been working
firm I mean like this point I wanted to
make about freedom of movement if you're
a North London lawyer you know you you
you can go and work in your your firm's
Berlin office you don't even have to you
know sign any sort of documentation
you're just gonna do it and live there
for two or three years it makes your
life better if you work in the food
production sector in Britain it's our
biggest sector by employment biggest
manufacturing sector my employer employs
400,000 people 120,000 of those people
come from Central and Eastern Europe
just since 2004 now you know and most of
the people who work in those factories
are not hosta personally hostile to the
people from Poland or Slovakia but they
think you know there is it a little a
little depress their wages and there
will be more competition for social
housing and public services in those
areas and people didn't have an
opportunity to to complain about that
because although because there was there
was a party consensus on European
membership and and and the Labour Party
was not complaining about it nobody was
doing anything about it
so a lot of those two or three million
people who had stopped voting because
they thought all the parties are the
same and they were partly right about
that came out and voted to break suit
they won't mildly perturbed perhaps a
bit more than my other term the idea
that some forms some people's anger is
more legitimate than others so I agree
that those people do have legitimate
causes concerned but if you're married
to an EU national for example and you're
now facing years of limbo
I don't feel that we somehow don't
intuitively feel but that anger is as
legitimate
sort of scene is a feature Ramona kind
of metropolitan liberal acts but there's
very absolute people who's not saying
that any of that we're talking about a
tiny number of people in that case I'm
it's just quantities of people and and I
want to hear you on this and then I've
got another question well firstly I
agree absolutely with Helen I think that
the the levels of poverty and the levels
of division in this country are nowhere
near as severe as and they are in the
United States whether it be CSU economic
or race actually I think America is a
different category altogether what I
would say there with the brexit vote is
you have two sorts of people you have
the comfortable 65 year old the Shia
Tories who are relatively well-off who
are you know voting for the past or vote
against immigration whatever it was but
then you have the sort of the labor
leave voters and I think there was anger
there and I don't think it was all
wholly immigration I think immigration
in many senses was a cipher there was a
growing sense that our communities have
been forgotten by politics that anger I
mean who could be a worse salesman of
the referendum to those communities than
George Osborne who stands up and says
things are great now you won't want to
change them would you and the resounding
answer is yes well actually frankly
things are outstanding
great for George Jones but he's gotten
jobs but but we let our country get to
the point where 17 million people a
large proportion of the lis voters were
willing to take a punt because they
didn't like where we'd got to and that's
an indictment of where we've got to as
much as anything else
III mean I agree with that it was about
both Europe and other things so your
communities have seen profound change
the old industries have gone on the
levels of employment and not they're the
kind of secure jobs paying a good wages
and I would sum it up like this the many
modern systems who wouldn't vote in a
general election came out to vote in the
referendum because they saw this as an
opportunity to influence what happens
and they would sum it out by saying we
don't like the way things are we don't
think it's working for us we didn't
think you were listening and the moment
result was declared that have looked all
of us in the eye and said you're
listening now aren't you and for them it
was a moment where they were able to
exercise that political power and that
is the challenge that our politics has
got both to respond to that because
somehow we have to bring the 52% and the
48% back together to
in a new future in the light of the
referendum which just very quickly which
is why I think if we don't see a big
shift in public opinion over the next 18
months the notion that we should somehow
stay in despite this anger would be
fatal to our politics because all those
people who were saying you're not
listening right well this reaffirms of
them and it'll make their anger much
deeper hang on so because I want to get
audience questions very soon but I've
got a couple more of my own I'm gonna
put it crudely do you think the next
year and more of you know to do about
bricks it could bust both these main
political parties ironically as somebody
pointed out earlier they got you know
both of them over well over 40% of the
vote in the last election but because
they're so both of them so cripplingly
divided on the brexit issue could bricks
it bust these parties well the great
thing whenever I'm asked to forecast
what's going to happen over the next be
now and Christmas over the next 18
months I always quite generally say
anybody who claims to be able to answer
that question for certain is fooling
himself or herself and everybody else
the extraordinary uncertainty that
always is created it's quite impossible
there is no one in control of events in
Westminster or anywhere else and or in
either party and we just don't know
where we're going and so it is
completely reassuring from the party I
think we were getting a bit members of
the liberal elite when we were denying
the level of anger and actually
hostility to religious system and so on
that recent votes have represented and
I'd what I do think of course is it's
extremely important to get back in
control of it but someone has got to
emerge who is capable of articulating a
sensible case for globalization for the
pace of change which they only don't
like anymore for addressing some of the
underlying problems which mean that many
many people don't think that they have
benefited from the otherwise prosperous
years of the last 20 years and they
think fear their children are going to
benefit even less
all things were touched on I'll try to
avoid the partisan way of addressing it
but we've got a very short time in which
to try to win back confidence in a
sensible political system at the moment
particularly when you go to some of the
places that we've already mentioned the
itches anger it's not rioting anger they
aren't disorderly people but inwardly
they want to express their rage at the
political system just one small point
it's not that they don't think they've
benefited they haven't benefited I mean
this isn't a perception this is reality
is that some people just haven't done
very well at all in fact I've done badly
out of what to us might have seen like a
glorious period of globalized growth I
mean we have aid the structural issues
about globalization and who's benefited
who hasn't to some extent but I now
wanted to turn to whether Party politics
is going to fundamentally change I mean
if I may say so and I don't wish to be
rude or question either of yours
political integrity but but you even in
the words you've said tonight are so out
of tune with your own party that I
wonder what it would take for you to
actually bugger off and leave it well I
mean I'm a center-right free-market the
social conscience no I believe in the
two-party system if it was this
particular issue it's now I'm not
revealing some great secret it's really
rather comic to see the leaders of the
two parties trying to reveal the equally
obvious position across both their
parties I do not agree with John redwood
on the grammar schools this is like
existential to the entire future of the
name flag you are arguing for a
cross-party approach in Parliament
because it seems to me the pretense of
the two front benches have to go through
that they've suddenly come up with some
new unifying position which is generally
unifying is so usually so vague and
ambiguous that they manage to get
everybody inside hit what we actually do
is TD but do is actually organized in
that hung parliament hung parliament
politics that can produce some consensus
so Hillary and I announced three
Jews are agreeing half the time another
penny well things week yeah but but but
75% of our audience tonight feel
politically homeless and not so long ago
before the shock of the last election
there were a lot of people and you know
people around Tony Blair and George
Osborne and Nick Clegg and da da da all
talking about you know the very urgent
need to start thinking about a new
political movement the election sort of
killed a lot of that but maybe Brittany
known all of the homeless people in here
tonight politically homeless people want
some serious talk about a new local
authority the Labour Party is much more
fragile than the Conservative Party on
this but partly because the Labour Party
voted base is absolutely split has it
has has different interests I mean it
has both the most zealous supporters and
the great beneficiaries of so many of
the changes of the last generation or so
the massive increase in higher education
the much greater openness the European
Union you know the university seats that
were overwhelmingly pro-labor that yeah
and on the other hand you've still got
you know that the left behind parts of
the country the D industrialised parts
the country which feel they're not part
of the national story any longer and and
some of those a lot of those actually
moved to the Tories and I think will
continue to do so they didn't do so in
the numbers that were required for the
Tories together to get a landslide but
that that is Labour's problem it's not
just that they're different sort of
social types they have conflicting
interests on the Great Western
democracies are in the same mess well
the other Europeans are the same move
they've all got five star movement per
day MA and the centrality for
Deutschland and the established party
system the old idea of big establishment
parties that every now and again change
in office when one was made a mess and
as the other ones turned take over
that's day but carefully swirlie
happened to the sense of less in
Evelyn's and it is worse their Social
Democrats yeah because the blue-collar
industrial working class and their
families have produced a massive
loyal Vanya for the Labour Party in this
country is much smaller than it was and
the older ones have gone off to the
right they're socially conservative and
it isn't only the labour
I mean we have problems as well with our
political base I'm trying not to be a
partisan this evening but the the labor
fight is particularly difficult their
support is polarized to extremely
right-wing very nationalists
anti-foreigner aging white working-class
people in the north and really very
modernizing the internationalist very
relaxed about a cosmopolitan multiracial
multicultural society who support them
in the south and southeast labor voters
you know in London do not resemble
labour vote if some other views on that
sudden fascinated by your view on this I
mean did you ever consider in your
darkest moments when you resigned from
the Shadow Cabinet consider when you
have no confidence in your leader and
da-da-da-da-da well did you consider
talking to these voices around Blair and
others and seriously thinking about
getting on board with something else no
oh you could say I was sort of born into
the Labour Party I am pretends to hang
on hang on I'm answering your questions
you just give me a second time I intend
to die in the Labour Party but not just
yet now to come back controversially
again to the question you asked is
bricks akin to bust and British politics
I'm much less worried about that than I
am a bad brexit busting the British
economy and our future as a nation and
the biggest single challenge that we
have got is is to try and bridge the
divide now that the way that I would put
it to my leave voters I would say I
respect the outcome the referendum I
campaigned to remain I lost I'm a
Democrat we're leaving the European
Union the institutions but what the
referendum result did not determine and
this is the issue for today is what our
future relationship is going to be with
our friends and neighbors and that is
where trade and market access and
cooperation on security and foreign
policy and data and health and indeed
the movement of workers
rests and I think the problem that we've
got it's taken the government a very
very long time and it is a it's a
partisan point to move from the nonsense
we could leave with no deal to say that
they would not need to be transitional
arrangements it's been painful we've
wasted time there is still a risk it
will go wrong and I'm reading the words
above us for inspiration I would love to
think about brexit when there would be
no more sorrow nor crying neither shall
there be any more pain but that is only
going to come to pass if the majority
that there is in the current House of
Commons is able to say to the government
these are the things that you now have
to do and it is plain as a pikestaff
that we are not going to negotiate this
all-singing all-dancing bespoke Vectrex
it deal by October next year we're going
to have to have transition arrangements
and as Kirsten are very clearly set out
in the summer that is going to involve
staying for a transitional period in the
single market and a cons union oh well I
want to hear from Helen and Anna and end
you and then Helen on this and and and I
you you're right you answered my
question the previous question I'd over
taken about us another one since then I
mean I asked about whether BRICS is
gonna bust British politics and then I
moved on to asking whether there was
whether BRICS it could be the motor for
a breakup of the two-party system if we
know for a new movement call it a party
called it what you will but a new
movement that BRICS it might bring to
the fore but take either of those points
and then on the second point I think
creating a new third party at a moment
when the big two parties have swept of
80% of the votes strikes me as odd so
that's where yes I don't see a future in
that but I actually do think the the
current debate about brexit is far less
of a problem for labour than it is about
the Tories I absolutely agree that when
we were discussing in or out Breck stood
or non brexit it was a real problem for
the Labour Party for the reasons you
gave but I think the problem the
Conservatives have is that Ken's
headbangers are committed to a path that
is gonna cause irreparable economic
damage and labour doesn't have a
grouping that's committed to self
economic self armed as a grouping that's
committed to leaving but they're more
open I think to softer forms of brexit
and I think they're actually the lie
labor have come up with whether through
good luck or good management which is we
want to brexit that preserves our
economy is actually a pretty coherent
one because it's in a certain direction
the majority in both parties a favor of
softness to the brexit you were talking
about the parliamentarians Hillary and I
are entirely agreed it's not a
revelation we both made speeches in the
House of Commons but even outside saying
the same things you just said it but
then we need a long transitional period
and we should stay in the single market
the customers you mean well the great
majority of MPs would be with that you
have the you neither party agrees with
that
well no party is against that and both
the leaders and that's why so many
people feel so homeless that the history
of the history of new parties is
catastrophic
everybody's been cured of that by the
history of the SDP and I particularly
agree that this would be a singly
inauspicious time for suddenly in a
former Blair rights and one nation
Tories to suddenly start talking about
forming certain a party with what's left
of the Liberal Democrats it's a it's a
popular thing to put in newspapers but I
think maybe practicing politicians if
they think that energy way to go even
further into now I'm just crippled by a
sense of futility here you're saying Oh
Hillary and I we represent the clear
majority in the House of Commons we're
all sensible and we know how to navigate
a path through this brexit mess and save
the country but frankly you may know
that to be the case but it's just not
happening and there's no sign of it's
ever going to happen over the next 18
months so Helen how how the only good
side of me is it will happen because I
don't think there's any practical or
turning consensus which actually crosses
both parties about not being absolutely
hardline on the European Court of
Justice I move we're moving towards of
fuzzy brexit but what we're getting yes
there is another side to this
negotiation i my fear is the EU are
gonna screw this up oh yeah alright
because they have some noodle and read
it well everything since the mid 1990s
but I watch euro you know the refugee
crisis and
and they're actually doing pretty badly
so far in this negotiation they come up
with a sequencing thing that we agreed
to but actually doesn't make sense
because we can't know how much we're
gonna pay in the bill until we know what
our trading relationship years and years
of practicing it and we've got kind of
civil servants that we've rustled up
from a cupboard somewhere and forced to
try never go there but I like to in
terms of a new political party I would
never rule that out I think Ken's right
if you you know how many times have I
sat and predicted something that wildly
failed to come to power did you feel in
your waters it might be happening you
know in the months before the election
yeah I did and there was a reason for
that is that we had a lot of discussions
people I talked to about what was
Labour's floor you know what was the
absolute baseline of what labor could go
down to and people saying maybe you know
20% and actually if you look at those
local election results from the force of
May labor on 28% I mean this is one of
the things of all the things that have
been busted about conventional political
wisdom the idea that campaigns don't
matter is the biggest casualty of this
year so the idea was that if you know
you just went in with your performance
six months out it was all decided that
was not true this year
so yeah there was pretty serious
conversations as I understand it
happening about a new party the reason I
wouldn't rule it out is because of
Emanuel micro in France now a very
different system to the one that we have
here but I still think if you had
somebody and no shade to in any of the
politicians present but I don't feel
that people are wildly inspired by any
of the politicians that they see around
them right I don't think people look at
Theresa May and think even if they voted
Tory I don't think there was no Blair
style wave behind trees maybe maybe
there is a bit behind Jeremy Corbyn you
might say among a particular segment of
people so if somebody came out you know
the only person I can think would be if
somebody like Ruth Davidson said I don't
want to be in a party that has just done
a deal with a very homophobic DUP and
I'm gonna start my own party if somebody
who like that who has that kind of
unique brand that is both were appealing
to working-class conservatives and also
to metropolitan liberals that's the kind
of person is he breaking it but as Ken
says the problem is everybody remembers
where are the lip what do they live Dems
Paul in this election 8% and then you
see you talk to Lib Dems now and they go
all these people say to me that they
want a liberal pro-european party and I
think that's us why does no one love us
and that's the problem for a third party
you know Angela Merkel famously said
about coalition's the little party
always gets crushed and that is the
exactly the story of British politics
but everything about macro surely is I
mean talented though he is the only one
because the Socialists collapsed and
feel had a court case about corruption I
mean it took that it took implosions on
left and right for a centrist party to
emerge and we've got the opposite here
we've got a Renaissance of the two big
parties so where's that where's the
space because he was anti-establishment
he's back to this angry protest again
yeah tweed Corbin gun he wasn't Corbin's
policies he wasn't the posters the
manifesto only one voter in a thousand
had a clue what the Labour Party's
policies were it was and say there's
roughly a thousand people saw you're
saying that only one of us had any clue
I think that's right I mean Hillary was
explaining hearing her ad and assaulted
it's my lord you've been involved in and
I it was revelation to me some of the
things you might say Corbin did actually
managed to capture some of the
anti-establishment quality Corbin one
thing he persuaded people in and an
awful election campaign where the public
was still switched off was who he wasn't
one of those politicians when they were
told that six hundred times he'd voted
against his own party's that was a very
good thing when he was on a platform he
was an ordinary chap talking and he
obviously wasn't a politician he was the
Bernie Sanders protest vote here whereas
the between the Donald Trump vote in in
the referendum campaign all right and
also but that what a lot of this makes
it easy to form this new all-singing
all-dancing centrist party which Tony
Blair use federal in Corbin easy fun
repeatable success I mean all of those
Tories in Kensington just up the road
from here are not going to vote labor
next are they so sure I mean I think
there's some ssin that you have to test
is can labor win by default
that's always something we thought labor
faces an uphill struggle and I just
think if you think about the fact that
public sector workers have faced in real
terms pay cut over the last ten years
you know look at the economy which is
always what drives elections and think
about the fact that the pound is now so
we can people feel poorer do we really
think that people are going to go into
the next election
thinking I'm really happy with
everything and then I I'm just happy
just to keep it ticking over like this I
think the lay but whether or not they
deserve it is another point whether
people agree with the policies a bit
different point but if you're going to
talk about these great big populist
revolts why would you bet against there
being one that puts Jeremy Corbyn in
number ten I would not very interesting
the point okay so we have reached that
moment ladies and Emma where I'm gonna
shut up and you'll all be delighted to
hear that and I want questions from the
floor and I suspect there gonna be lots
of them the only thing you have to
forgive is that there are very fierce
light so it's a little bit difficult to
see hands but what I'm gonna do is take
a bunch of two or three at a time from
different areas of the hall so trying to
see what I'm doing if we go number three
is a microphone so if we take a couple
of questions from that area where the
gentleman's got the microphone you go
first sir yeah in 2012 a Morrie poll of
the country asking about grievances and
worries people spontaneously talked
about all the things that David's got in
his book all those somewhere people
grievances like immigration like access
to public services and all that stuff
but they didn't talk about Europe Europe
was down the bottom of those spontaneous
concerns right how does the panel think
over that period Europe was moved into
center stage as the proxy for all those
legitimate grievances you make it's the
question of agency or as Helen would say
campaigns how was that done okay thank
you
let's take at least one more from your
area of the hall can we get the mic to
that gentleman yes right there you go on
so you're gonna get the mic in a moment
give us your question pithy as possible
please the key to a centrist party is
its leader if you have a good leader
it's got a chance if you have a bad
leader not a hope in hell
I personally believe there is only one
possible leader yes I can't think of
anybody else I'm greatly in favored and
he is David Miliband what does the panel
think David Miliband not in the hall
tonight is he all right let's take these
two in order first question how come how
is it that the Europe became the proxy
for all of these feelings of alienation
and pissed-off nurse that that people
were feeling before but actually one
they weren't that bothered about Europe
they were alienated about a whole lot of
stuff and David's written about plenty
of it but Europe wasn't anyway near the
top of their list of problems and and
suddenly you know Europe has become the
proxy for all this how come well it's
very I mean if you look at those Ipsos
MORI trekkers they're really interesting
because as you rightly say Europe never
figured near the list near the top of
people's concerns even immediately
before the referendum on those trackers
Europe wasn't there the trackers that
were done around the last election were
very interesting because brexit came top
an immigration for the first time in God
knows how many is didn't figure on the
list so it's precisely that phenomenon
of being a proxy brexit is boxed up a
load of concerns that people have and
they're not gonna be solved by brexit
because there are so many conflicting
ones you know and brexit has become a
cypher for those things and it became a
cypher for those things because brexit
post referendum was the only story in
town I mean we've heard nothing but
brexit every since the refere but we
love a bit of blame blaming for all the
for well before allowing brixi to become
this proxy for so much else and arguably
too many in the country doing the
country a disservice it was an
extraordinary politician whether he
agree with him or not he took a you know
he took all of the BMPs all voters he
took a big chunk of old conservative
voters he melded it together he spoke to
people in a language that they felt they
understood he was incredibly good on TV
he was inviting scheme enormous airtime
to air his views and as you can see from
you clip afterwards no-one else hasn't
matched that success I think you just
have to say that without him Briggs it
would not
one who realized think he was one who
realize I made a proxy but the reason is
a very successful proxy and attracts all
these votes shouldn't it in the the
referendum is firstly it is simple and
the Hillary been in American law reports
is here switch people off there that's
dismissed his policy wonks because they
talk about extremely complicated
questions and these protesting voters
don't want that they want someone to
simplify or qualitex of amongst they
want scapegoats the simple solution they
want is Lee you tell me who's to blame
and if you say gray men in Brussels
jean-claude Juncker who you know
frightened your children with when they
go to bed all these foreigners
authorized realize that he leads
immigration with Europe and found it
worked he never went on about Polish
plumbers much he appeared in front of
posters that had Muslim Middle Eastern
refugees on an Eastern European border
and never explained that whether these
people could ever come to settle in this
country if they wanted to had absolutely
nothing to do with our membership of the
European Union we were a sovereign state
right well they made that decision
thanks said he brilliantly mobilized
this protest he used the simple answer
let's handle open all panel panel it
just as I said questions after pithy
answers after 52 so he camera David
Cameron oh I agree with what he's share
of the credit the blame should not
disappear in this discussion because
Nigel Farrar's created a force that
started to take votes in truth from both
of our parties and in the end David
Cameron reached the conclusion and this
this is why that he couldn't manage and
the problems in his own party and so he
looked back to what Harold Wilson had
done 40 or so years previously when the
Labour Party was split on membership of
the Common Market and he drew exactly on
a renegotiation and referendum thinking
he would win and when you ask the
question then you may get the answer
that you don't like so it was his
decision fundamentally to hold of the
referendum
right well there's a reason why it's not
getting too hung up on on that although
it is interesting but it was the ability
came about
controlled it I mean taking back control
with a very very powerful slogan because
yeah there is a positive reason for
voting brexit is about self-government
that feeling that Brussels have come to
represent the technocratic state all of
those things that keep being taken out
of the Democratic conflict now the Bank
of England becomes independent we have
all this judicial activism so many
decisions are now taken outside of the
Democratic conflict and Brussels was the
was the example of that par excellence
people wanted self-government and now
taking back control at this point
because very briefly I want an end I
want you to answer the second query that
our question is said you know in his
view the key to a centrist party is
finding the right credible leader and he
says he can think of only one David
Miliband are you with him or against him
well I don't suppose my opinion of David
Miliband I doesn't mean against millions
the question is I think I think the
leader is one of the issues I think
there are other ones as well I think
there is the state of the two parties
and as I said at the moment they are in
a very rude health so I think it's a
Roman and there is an electoral system
that directly pushes you towards a
two-party system and I think for those
two reasons regardless of who's in
charge it is not a great moment to
Hillary if David Miliband issued the
most emotional rallying cry possible for
you to join his movement sort of macro
Miliband movement how would you respond
I'm I gave you the answer earlier I'm a
Labour through and through and I'm not
going anywhere else
Miliband is not back wrong this game is
escaping from all these complicated
issues it is a simple solution leader
doesn't matter you know
and then my party I've said it reports
picked up some women I said to somewhere
else when they can't think we need to do
we have a leadership contest it's a and
there's a section of the public that
want the simple solution when they're
not just finding scapegoats they want to
choose a new leader rather like choosing
who wins trick to come i'm just very
briefly there
David I thought the I thought the
questioner might have suggested David
Owen he's a bit old now it's true but I
mean David Owen representing in it in a
way that you were saying that that that
the Scottish roof does that kind of
about potentially that hard center the
ability to bring these value groups
together and he would see he was
politician who'd always argued in favor
of let's go to the back and on this side
we've got the the number for microphone
so let's Hoover up some questions in
that area so we've got yeah let's take
three at once but keep them really short
and I'll try and keep the panel short to
go on and in terms of talking about the
divide between young and old I think
we've got to kind of recognize that
whether or not it's specifically related
to a brexit in terms of identity whether
people voted remain or leave or kind of
as a result of brexit that the other
things are being ignored how do young
people who have kind of grown up with
this kind of got to this point with this
open and kind of the the way that we
have been since 97 as a kind of pinpoint
how do we kind of have our say because I
feel like it's a little bit it's kind of
been passed over and actually the fact
that young people are gonna be the ones
who actually come in as brexit is is
having an effect how do young people
feel like they can actually have a
proper say and that actually their
identity the fact that actually identity
is an important issue in fact that you
might feel like personally I feel like a
bit of my identity has been taken away
from me whether or not that emotionally
is recognized or not how can we kind of
yeah right to consideration okay I'll
get that one out to the panel can we
bring the microphone down a bit to
gentleman waving his arm right there
it was one of the sort of flag staffs of
the brexit campaign that we'd take back
control usually one assumed that would
be through our Parliament how can one
have any confidence in where we're going
when a we don't seem to be understanding
our
Constitution and be in Parliament right
now we're trying to reverse matters that
seem to have come to a head by the
execution of Charles the first were
going back further to Henry the eighth's
trying to use powers that we fought
Kings to wrest from them it's absolutely
crazy and we don't know where we're
going
would you agree right there's nothing
like a non prejudicial question that's
wonderful one more for the the gentleman
who's nearest there don't worry we're
gonna come to other areas of the hall
but we're gonna stick with that area for
now yet go on sir
make an observation I recollect 20 years
ago that can you turn into a question
because then well well I want to make an
observation first of all which is that
which is which is that we're all as
confused as you are 20 years ago I
remember education the Armed Forces
health care security being the major
issues and now we have so many important
issues notwithstanding all of those
including global warming Scottish
independence war in other countries and
it's very difficult to identify which
are the primary issues because our
identity our choice of politics how does
one prioritize which of those issues is
the most important and I don't think our
politicians are giving us a clear lead
on which of those very many more
important issues we should choose to be
the most important and that's what I'm
confused about okay yeah yeah all right
good well we've got three here so let's
chew these over without further ado we
had a young person in the audience
saying how do young people who were you
know they've grown up in a relatively
open Britain if we can use that phrase
David how can they have a proper say in
the current debate when when so many
feel that what is happening is robbing
them of a bit of their identity well I
would say there two things that you can
do and that's vote and buy newspapers
and that's a very partisan thing for me
to say as a member of the media but we
saw youth Turner was up at this election
and that's one
reasons why the result was as it was but
the classic thing has always been that
old people will vote the over 65s will
gain outs upon this so that shifts the
electoral incentives so far in their
favor that's why you end up with things
like the triple lock on pensions your
pensions going up by the rate of
inflation at a time when wages for
working people aren't and the second
thing in terms of buying newspapers the
Daily Mail whatever you think about it
advocates incredibly hard and incredibly
well for the constituency it represents
where is the equivalent that does that
for 18 to 24 year olds in our public
life it does not exist and you have to
unfortunately ask them the trade union
movement probe if you care about
something you have to put time you have
to put money into it and young people
need to have those kind of lobbying
organizations that feel dependent on
them and the only way you can do that
unfortunately is with money and putting
your money where you know into things
like momentum or whatever it is or Young
Conservatives if such a thing still
exists you know you have to you have to
get involved you have to give up time
and energy and ultimately sacrifice some
portion of your wages to it that's it
okay one more and then you are you say
two things I'd say yeah absolutely vote
and I think one of the things we'll see
at the next election is that our parties
take young people seriously now and they
will figure in the election because they
suddenly dawned on us that they vote but
we've got an old population so you can't
blame young people for this I mean the
fact is that you'd have needed I think
it's a hundred and twenty percent
turnout amongst under 25s to turn the
Vectrex it vote round you'd have needed
a 97 percent turnout over of under 40s
to turn the referendum results around
the fact is we're an aging Society so
partly young people have got the thin
end of the wedge just demographically
but because I mean I do think there is
also a bit of a myth here that you
somehow every one under 24 is gonna be
imprisoned in the UK for the next 50
years I mean I've heard Vince Cable more
or less saying this on on radio actually
relatively little is going to change in
terms of openness we're going to
continue to have visa-free travel that
the Erasmus yes we are well that's
that's only what the British government
wants we are with the Erasmus system
welcome to max all right well I mean
there is a massive interest for on both
sides of the tourist industry you know
in both
and Britain has a massive interest in
visa-free trouble and we we will one way
or another get it at the Erasmus system
universities will continue you will
still be able to go to do a year at a
European University if you want to
anyway and about only about half of the
current exchanges go through Erasmus
anyway you know right not change that
much in relation to Europe enough ok can
I come to the second question which was
about the EE you withdraw well I think
you were referring to now Henry the
eighth's in 1539 I suppose I think he
was in between wives at the time when he
issued his proclamation but you cannot
look at the terms of the EU withdraw
bill that we've been debating over the
past couple of days and square that with
a ringing declaration that we are taking
back control and which is why the bill
is gonna have to be significantly
amended during its course through
Parliament to answer the last question
no blow me yeah that's very kind of you
but since the gentlemen are stick well
what is the biggest challenge that we
face as a world it is how we're going to
deal with the increasing interdependence
of human beings by the time my
grandchildren are my age they've been
living on this planet with 10 billion
fellow citizens and what the referendum
result demonstrated is we are struggling
to find the right balance between
influence at home dealing with the
problems that we can identify and coming
to terms with an absolute necessity for
International Cooperation to make sure
that we are able to live independently
in peace and security say 10 billion
fellow citizens in fellow humans you
mean the world you're a citizen of
nowhere that's what Theresa May says but
I take your point losses when I
abstained on the second reading of this
bill because I'm not gonna support it
until these amendments are brought
forward it needs to be changed and I
have voted against the government on the
timetable motion and so on but the house
is still full of people who won't do
that because they pay deference this
blasted referendum which they all say
they've been instructed by the people
and so on
and actually it's a question of
parliamentary of Parliament go his
appeal there's a bigger question
Parliament is much weaker now than it
was when I first joined in Parliament
and this has been a continuing process
going on for some time
I do think Tony Blair had a lot to do
with it he took away the weapon of time
from the opposition and from groups it
was all dressed up as family friendly
hours it was to make sure that they
didn't talk too much about difficult
things the government had more control
of the business and the ministers all
knew they had to come to vote for 10
minutes at 7 o'clock then they could go
away again and unfortunately over recent
years it's been developed but I can
that's precisely why when you said
earlier Oh Hillary Hillary and I agree
on so much and I can assure you that's a
majority of MPs we're going to be
sensible on brick's it that's why I'm so
i think i think it will be amended and i
hope it will be a reversal of the
process the present minister is citing
precedents from the Blair government for
these clauses and if are allowed to get
away with just future ministers from any
part I will cite what he's doing the
bigger problem is Parliament music the
government's it's too controlled by
newspapers for younger people it's not
going to be newspapers best thing
younger people could do to intervene in
this start organizing some serious
debate on the social media which is the
only source of political debate for the
majority of people under the age of 50
moment in an old fogies opinion it is
prejudiced it's a silly it's largely
based on insults everybody confirms
their own views by only exchanging them
with people who agree with them once
that becomes a developed debate and
influences the next generation of people
where politics will change I think
politics for a whole variety has changed
to the better parliamentary power might
be restored by this current mess over
brexit because we're not going to get
anywhere unless the majority of the
House of Commons who can broadly agree
in what they want start coming together
start making the government do what is
in my opinion the National I want one
other panelist to Hillary gave an
impassioned response to this idea of you
know what must the priorities be going
forward we were all
fuse is not clear that that there is a
consensus politically on what the the
most important priorities for Pollock
Wiener UK politics be wrestling with our
right now so and then give me your sense
of you know very short your sense of
what our top priorities ought to be not
what what they actually are but what
they ought to be I think a priority for
our politicians and of our system is
that politics need to regain the trust
of the people in governance that has got
to be front and center of this because
actually from that comes everything else
from that comes inclusiveness from that
comes people's participation at this
moment we're going for an odd moment in
this country at the moment where you
have like a surge in Labour Party
membership or whatever but there is
still that lingering distrust of the
people who govern us and I think that
should be a priority for those in what
okay I think we've got time for one more
tranche of three questions we haven't
been in this central area down the front
so conveniently we've got three very
eager hands so could we take these three
questions right I think the whole thing
Hillary been saying that there are a
large majority of parliamentarians who
are thinking along the same lines are
you surprised the public doesn't trust
you or believe you we were sold a whole
lot of lies in the vote and you have
none of you have come up with any answer
except to say eventually you'll come to
your senses
how are you going to come to your senses
alright okay well I asked for pithy and
I got I got pithy Thank You Madame I bet
I did promise some people bit further
back so where's the microphone now can
we go to I promised that gentleman with
the black shirt who's looking so
pleading at me there you go thank you
very much if it's true that in the
run-up to brexit public confidence in
politicians with an all time law there's
no deer of confidence and they're all
crooks does the panel think there's a
relationship between that lack of
confidence and the weakening of
Parliament and how easy it was for those
so-called leaders to package all these
proxy concerns into the white van of
brexit where where the leaders I mean
where gorvan
bors and Farraj and Liam Fox for God's
sake were they really the leaders
leading us all into this is the whole
thing not a crisis of leadership is the
whole Briggs that mess not symptomatic
of a crisis of leadership and what did
the panel think we should do about okay
right one more from this this sector
it's frankly its lucky dip whoever gets
the mic first ma'am you I think you've
you've won the raffle there you go
I might Machiavelli work his way out of
this mess I love questions like that
because I don't have to answer them but
somebody else does
good all right first one I suppose this
was primarily anger directed at Ken and
Hillary for you know where you lie in
Parliament gonna come to your senses you
are the only tear in part of this
ridiculous the integration the political
practices just shows the questioner
shares this ridiculous adolescent
cynicism which has been cultivated over
the last 20 years in my experience
people into politics by and large are
motivated by some clear views of
national interest and having worked in
other areas of life some in business
some in the law I think the ethical
standards of the average member of
Parliament's are very much higher than
those of the general public and there
[Applause]
ever since about 6:00 or dozen of them
started fiddling their expenses which is
proportion of 650 it's probably a lower
proportion many many leading businesses
in this country including journalism and
the public are being swept along by some
of these fashionable nonsense and there
is a genuine policy dilemma the
parliamentarians have to be allowed to
start engaging with the extremely
complex issues which weren't even
addressed in the referendum as you quite
rightly say the figures who took the
public eye if the people who got in the
national media debate we're taking
ridiculous and sometimes quite dishonest
points on both sides the general public
heard no debate about how we were going
to leave most members of the main
republic aren't quite sure what we're
talking about now on the single market
end the customs union I am told this and
ordered by my constituents by a result
microsystems Reiter domain but I'm told
I'm ordered by the public opinion to
leave your Atem then most of the people
I meet have no views on your attic
honorable Parliament it is an
opportunity for Parliament to take back
control I don't know how it's going but
that's a point but it's not helped when
the public just say oh well it's also
you know just give us a simple answer
it's all silly anyway and you are
obviously like me it disappointed remain
there so you think we should all agree
just to go back to where we were if we
could do that I'd be very happy but in
the real world these things are more
complicated than that and it's the
benefit I have the song how do you have
or Hillary either of you who sit in the
House of Commons
how is Parliament going to reassert its
its power over this process you say oh
so much the debate was driven and
influenced by people who weren't either
necessarily parliamentarians or telling
the truth so how are these truth-telling
parliamentarians the sensible majority
going to reassert themselves in the
committee stage of this bill which is
only a very preliminary
a sort of you know a sort of seed
setting thing but it'll be a good
experiment in seeing I mean if the
government can just maintain a policy
for whatever they would finally manage
to agree on the day before or but by
just calling on I don't know party
loyalty or saying everybody's been
instructed by the referendum I
personally wish that people would stop
paying deference this referendum is held
for cynical reasons it was a dreadful
campaign people answered a broad-brush
question which contain hundreds of other
questions simply because they were angry
about something or rather and often not
because of Europe at all and now I hear
every politician say I mean everybody
Hillary has to begin by saying of course
I respect democracy and the judgment of
the other people let's get what the
second point there's no judgment at all
being exercised by the people on the
many detailed things that are going to
have to be negotiated for a new place in
the world where we're gonna go at the
risk of breaking the consensus I do
respect the outcome the referent for the
reason that we began discussing tonight
if Parliament as we were urged had
decided not to vote in favor of the
article 50 legislation then indeed the
52% would have turned around and if you
think we have a crisis of confidence in
our politics tonight which is the
premise of our discussion believe you me
we would have a crisis of confidence in
our politics and Annan made the point
earlier because people would say you're
just treating us with contempt you're
telling us we didn't know what we were
doing and that is why we have to
distinguish between the decision to
leave the institutions which is going to
happen and frankly the answer to your
question is the government coming to its
senses we are seeking to do our job by
pointing out that the the path on which
the government set out was never going
to be sustainable I mean the amount of
effort that's gone into trying to
persuade the government to stop inanely
saying no deal is better than a bad deal
no deal is the worst possible deal of
all and that is part of the truth that
has to be said and our job in the end is
to use our votes in Parliament and
people will make attempts during the
course reach passage of this bill to be
able to put
the government in the direction and the
end instructed by voters in Parliament
if it doesn't come to in senses which it
needs to do pretty darn quickly right we
I think we sort of tangentially
addressed the second question about the
you know the brexit situation we're in
being symptomatic of lack of
parliamentary Authority da da da we sort
of did a bit of that in the course of
this conversation so I want to end
because we're almost out of time and I
everybody sort of has to make their way
home before too long
how might Machiavelli respond to the
situation we are in today you would have
invaded another Italian problem I'm not
sure we can draw that many lessons from
Machiavelli on this one do we want would
we blame would we benefit from having a
super smart Machiavelli in charge right
now Machiavelli in charge of a leave
campaign Dominic Cummings right and I
think that's one of the things that
people all of all sides would
acknowledge and actually the trouble
sometimes with very very smart people is
that they assume that everyone else is
stupid and I think that's one of the
things I think is a real danger and it
comes back to what I was saying at the
start about this idea about governing
for by graduates for graduates is there
is there is too much of an assumption
that if you just put a lot of clever
people in charge they will govern in the
interests of other clever people and
actually you've got a governing the
interest of everybody right Machiavelli
might have pointed out that we have a
pretty on representative panel tonight
all of us voted remain as far as I am as
far as I know all of us voted by I'm not
telling you I voted well I'm guessing
you voted remain but that may be wrong
that may be wrong but just this point
about trust can't just we unwilling it
is for the bird the idea that trust in
politics is going to be restored it's
the kind of thing that one says at these
occasions it is not going to happen
they wouldn't have a trusted politicians
let me go back to the Second World War
extraordinary polling figures about how
Leo Churchill was mistrusted by
everybody we live in an anarchic messy
much more liberal society much higher
levels of education we are not going to
go back to some good old days where
everybody trusted the politicians and
thank God for that
all right well ladies and gentlemen the
the the the the witching hour has just
passed because it is 9 o'clock and
and a minute pass so I really think
unfortunately because I'm just so
enjoying listening to my panel
unfortunately I'm gonna have to draw
things to a close so before I do and
before I think you all I just want to
thank my panel so Ken Clark Helen Lewis
David good heart Hilary Benn and Menon
Thank You panel thank you
[Applause]
tonight
I just want to I want to send you into
this London good night by thanking all
of you before being a fabulous audience
everything from the voting to the
questions fantastic enjoy the rest of
your evening and thank you very much
indeed
[Applause]